So due to the client server interactions
that happen with the system,
I'm giving you one
specific example here.
A client makes a call to a file system.
And the directory server
of the file system
makes call to the data server where
the file is actually located.
So all of these are IPC calls, but
under the cover a shadow graph structure
emerges which is a trail of
the client server interactions.
The client opening the file so
the TM on the owner has a link to
a TM on the directory manager and
the directory manager
is calling the data servers and
two different nodes and correspondingly,
there is a link from the transaction
manager on the directory server
to the transaction manager on the data
server on these two different nodes.
So, if you look at it from the point
of view from the transaction tree,
the client is the owner of
the transaction tree and
all of these sites are participants
in the transaction tree.
I mentioned earlier that as
the owner of a transaction tree,
the owner has the right to delegate
the ownership to someone else.
Why would they want to do that?
We think about it from the point of
view of the distributed system that we
are talking about.
The most fragile parts of
the distributive system are the clients.
They are the fickle minded
ones who can go away,
who can abort a file request
that they started, and so on.
So in that sense if the root of
the transaction tree is on a client node
then cleaning up the bread crumbs may
become hard if the client box goes away.
Because the owner will go away, and
that's the reason the owner can delegate
the ownership to any node
in the system and that
node becomes the transaction manager for
this particular transaction tree
in terms of what needs to be done to
clean up anything that happens adversely
during the interaction that I'm showing
you in this particular picture.
So the heavy lifting that Quicksilver
does has to do with what it
needs to do under the covers in keeping
this order tree of transactions.
Corresponding to the IPC interactions
from the point of view of recovery.
Let's talk about how this
order chain is managed
by Quicksilver in order to
facilitate recovery management.